you're watching the GameSpot co-op stage
sponsored by Lego Star Wars The Force
awakens
everybody welcome back to e3 2016 at the
GameSpot co-op stage thank you some
pitter-patter of applause as many people
walk their demo I'm one of your hosts
Greg Miller from kind of funny alongside
Tim from kind of funny what's the most
Nick from kind of funny hello and Jove
Stauffer from Telltale Games Oh Gregory
so much to talk to you about what an
exciting time for telltale thank you
right we saw we saw your your kind of
fun to reiax videos right yes
what's the two nights ago I did it to
the screenshots of Batman yes and you're
like how can they all do that then you
put out a teaser trailer for Walking
Dead Season three try to go for a
one-two punch on Sunday let's try and
get it out before the incredible Sony
conference all your dreams to it
happened your dreams to it happen but
that's the thing is that the dreams all
started so early for me there are so
many things happening that I'm glad you
enjoyed it so where do you want to start
you if you want to talk about Batman you
want to talk about it tell Batman Batman
okay well I guess we're talking about
I wouldn't saw Batman today you didn't
you can really actually the first person
outside of tell tells doors to see no he
doesn't mean it
no to get him in to see it alright let's
start then I put up a video of course
instagram.com slash game over Greggy uh
showing your boot your booth is amazing
you guys always have cool booths thank
you to go hang out in with this one you
walk in it's Wayne Manor there's some
cigars there's some drinks happening if
you wanna and then there's a cloth you
push the clock out of the way you walk
into the Batcave
right the big back computer is there
Nick they do the demo on the
bat-computer I'm excited I'm hearing you
say this yeah it's getting me excited
then I'm gonna watch your Instagram
video and that's gonna actually really
give me jacked up oh you mean mr. Graham
calm
that very same one thank you very much
that sounds really fun
but then jumping into the game it's what
I expected it not you you know you guys
invited me to South by Southwest to do
the first panel about Batman and even
there you know Kevin talked about the
fact that it's gonna we're getting
physics we're doing this it's gonna be a
different engine but you still I
expected it to look more like how and
act more like I thought Walking Dead
does or how tales the borderlands does
and it doesn't it's very fluid it's very
thanks the Cape physics are great the
look of the game is great even tell its
telltale but it doesn't feel like the
negative way that's the thing it's like
we're never gonna go down that direction
where we're gonna look hyper real you
know we love all the games that are
going in that direction but we move very
fast and we're episodic so we're based
on comic books we won't go for a living
comic book feel for us realism is you
know it's really in the writing in the
storytelling and you know we we've done
this before if you I know that you still
have it play wolf among us but I started
a wolf among us boring and I thought I
think you should get out
Schatzi more than meets the eye that's
the thing every time I say that I guess
eat a lot better visually you know I
think we're we're trying to land
somewhere between wolf among us and sort
of a living Gimli comic book alright so
now Nick you're a big Batman face yeah
what do you want to know well this I
mean first off I'm excited about this
largely because up to this point like
when you when I first heard about it I'm
like that's a lot a little bit of an odd
fit especially coming off of the Arkham
series being very reactionary again very
critically acclaimed great series then
once you started thinking about you're
like well what does tell it's all great
at storytelling what do I love most
about the Batman just about any general
storytelling this actually is gonna be
this is very exciting for me today I
really want to play this I want to
everything about it so could you tell me
you start to finish how it unfolds let
me say no or the whole here's the entire
thing good thing
well what are we allowed to talk about
what do we can we talk in the demo so
the demo is only behind closed door okay
we're only seeing sort of the first 30
minutes even before the opening credits
roll I can't wait for cuz you guys have
been on a roll
lately thanks I mean one of your credit
credit to our team for the credit yeah I
know you don't
yeah well yeah your tailor the
borderlands your minecraft always
opening with a great song in slow motion
I'm really excited to you sorry open so
we just wanted we've been saying that
this is a Batman game that is just as
much a Bruce Wayne game as it is sort of
seeing the bat suit okay and that's
really kind of where we're going here
we've we loved all the other Batman
games we've seen we love battling for 75
years there's comics and movies and TV
shows and games and so many artists
directors writers developers have really
had their chance to sort of do their
take on Batman this is ours awesome
it's not an action game it is full of
action it's full of crime drama villainy
sort of all the themes of a Batman story
it's just done in the Tulsa Way and it's
it's just as much a Bruce Wayne like
things you'll be doing as Batman say
you're like if you're in the middle of a
fight in our demo you're actually
fighting Selina Kyle and we thought
there are things that could happen in
the middle of that sort of that stuff
Allah that the city's watching there's
like police cameras and helicopters
hovering around above the rooftops
anything that you do up there has the
potential to be reported in Gotham news
and if there's a moment between me and
Selena they're gonna know about that
everyone will know
so yeah boy autumns always watching
battle I get it done and everything
you're doing the city's saying that okay
that's sort of on a grandma it's crazy
that's all we're also kind of at a point
in in our Canon where it's it's not like
his first year doing this but he has
some experience okay we're putting on
this suit cool and the city's still not
really sure if he's a nuisance or a hero
they're still kind of deciding whether
brew your decisions really do matter you
do so
oh that's just happening and that's
that's sort of only one half of our demo
the other half you are you're sort of
walking out into a gala after this fight
Batman Batman Dallas and you are
supporting mural Canon candidate Harvey
Dent's are one of your best friends we
all know how that turns out and
that's happening at Wayne Manor and just
as much as the city's watching Batman
and everything he's doing they're
watching Bruce and interesting
everyone's that oh you know all the
biggest people supporting the campaign
and the fundraiser and watching Bruce
there they're seeing what he's doing and
what he's saying
Vicki Bale shows up she has questions
for you she's not invited by the way she
just showed up and you know it's she's
watching everything you're doing and
what you're saying got it who walks in
Falcone so that was the really cool
thing it's like I think from the get-go
you guys have been very clear that as
much as you're Batman you're Bruce Wayne
and so interacting with Harvey was
interesting because they I love they
haven't you know the dialog pops up for
you to choose and they have the lines in
there like making a reference to face
like you can if you want to start
playing about the beaver I think I think
a choice options I would change the face
of God yeah exactly exactly so but
you're going through and then yeah I was
having this banter with him and he's on
the inside you are real friends it's
like I know you don't like doing I don't
you knows you're Batman I know you don't
like doing these parties or whatever but
play along and then when Falcone shows
up he is like immediately starts pushing
buttons of like being an he's a dick
obviously he's right I've lured every
knows it so what Bruce goes to meet him
like he puts out his hand to shake them
and you can shake it or not you get the
entire parties watching that's great
everything Bruce is doing everyone sees
that and it's just as much sort of an
action thriller as it is sort of you
know we watch shows like house of cards
or Mad Men it's kind of got that going
on the same time it has sort of a Batman
Michael Mann thing going it sounds like
there's an underlying level of tension
that's gonna give me anxiety at night
but in a good way what we hope in a good
way I mean it's a normal telephone thing
where your decisions matter yes yeah I'm
most excited about the Bruce Wayne stuff
okay so we've seen the Batman men stuff
a lot and it's been awesome no for sure
we love obviously man I can't wait for
the Batman stuff in this game too but
what excites me about the Bruce Wayne
stuff is you know Bruce Wayne we got the
guy that's you know without the mask on
but then there's also he's kind of the
facade Greg always talks about this how
Bruce Wayne is more of the character
that Batman acts
right this all playboy a loop character
these players that Bruce Wayne or as
always just the guy without the mask on
well it's role-playing is kind of that's
up to you
we're letting you play Bruce and play
Batman the way that you kind of want to
play him it kind of goes down that Lane
where he's not really sure who he is and
he's still figuring out like he's
dedicated towards his Knightly Crusades
and he knows there's a purpose and he
knows that this is justified this is own
version of justice right but he's also
starting to I don't want to spoil
anything he saw this with Falcone kind
of questioning his own roots and
questioning the Wayne family yeah I
think everything he knows about his own
family and his own legacy is kind of up
for up first up for rediscovery sure and
I'll say no more
that's what I dug about not the Falco
stuff but in terms of identifying what
Batman you're going to be right even
with a conversation with Selina and when
she's in her Catwoman outfit you have
that option of like why do you do this
but she says that it could be like a
Sudanese a protector or it's about it's
it can even be about like hope for the
city are about fear for the criminals or
like you can start to see where you
he's malleable for the way right now I
want him to be this terrifying object or
I want him to be like you know Golden
Age fat man of like I'm helping out the
little guy it's really all about making
it your own Batman than your own Bruce
which way did you go Greg terrify they
don't let me touch it but I got I was I
was saying yeah you know I wanted the
hope I wanted the hope angle okay I'm
doing this because the city needs to it
when I get there there's a few times I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna [ __ ] be
addictive Falcone up so you're right now
oh yeah come Richard loved that article
yeah yeah Richard Bolling if you're
playing on charge that's the one thing
when you got to get Richard McGonagall
into the kind of funny office Wilson
he's a friend of mine kind of sort of
where's he been yet no I posted panels
with them what and we were it was like I
was like I can't believe I'm tryna forum
like I can't believe I finally meeting
you here isn't all evening or whatever
he's like yeah
I'll tell you what Greg I don't mean to
err private business here probably but
one of the things we're gonna be like we
want we want this whole game to be a
conversation we've done things in the
past Walking Dead we're talking about
these these episodes as they go through
we're gonna start our own sort of talk
show that's gonna be happening and
there's a good chance that we could have
the cast on and between episodes we're
going to think to my office
who's gonna host the talk show I think I
think we still need a house so I think
if I think if you hear a calling for it
perhaps uh perhaps you could we're not
that far away I enjoy Batman I'd love to
come talk about all I think Greg Miller
would be good at it Thank You Samson
thank you the backup house would be
great at it to know Colin would be
following tell us biggest fan the
biggest so what else do you want to
touch on on Batman before we have to
walk you know just it's you know we're
we're still working on this first
episode it's gonna be premiering this
summer digital download basically
everywhere you play games and gets us
back to the five Episode run it's five
of us of run it's gonna be on the season
pass disc - you wanna have a nice shiny
disc on your shelf and play it live play
as we go along and we're gonna be
watching you we're gonna watch watch
your feedback online we're gonna see
every choice that you've made and and
we're gonna be sort of adjusting and
tailoring sort of this series as it goes
along we have part of development play
the game as it's live and join us
conversations awesome that's it very
cool
so now oh gosh The Walking Dead Season 3
yeah really how old is Clint so well you
know when we kicked off the season she
was eight and you knew by the end of the
season she had just her 9 into season
two you choose a bat 11 so we can't
exactly say where we are in the timeline
now but I would say 13 or 14 okay so
early teenager one of the question is I
mean Tim brought up when we were doing
it go ahead yeah so recently I I've just
been welcomed into the Walking Dead
universe for years I've been kind of
like and I don't a thing but Greg
finally when we over watched all the
show read all the comics I'm super soul
started playing
episode 1 of season 1 with my girlfriend
first video game she ever play together
and she yeah she's totally enjoyed I had
a great time a little problem aiming but
that's more of a her thing now to you
guys thanks so really really enjoying it
but what I like is that it's in the
comic kind of timeline continuity there
so where's this fall then with the
comics so it's the 3rd season now is up
to where the comics are presently I'm
going out with her issues
so we're past the time jump or sort of
past all the events of you know the
prison and Alexandria and just kind of
where the show is kind of butting up
against now and like he thinks so that's
where we are it's it's present but you
don't you absolutely don't need to have
read the comic that shouldn't be a
barrier you should they're fantastic we
encourage you to but and the season also
it's like it's it's really a new entry
point as well oh cool so if you saw the
teaser
we've got Clem's she's back and
depending on where you left her off in
season 2 you cut off part of her finger
I saw well that's that's going to be the
result of something you may or may do or
may have already dodged save the finger
Greg save the finger figure save the
girl yeah this newcomer Javier we've not
seen him before
yeah he's not been in the comic dumpin
in the show he is effectively the main
playable character along the flem super
important no do we play acid you will
absolutely play a while guy probably
more than you're thinking I would say
we're in play it's fun to you are gonna
play spawn there the other characters
yeah other players that other players
yeah I wouldn't say any just yet but
it's these two if you played tales from
the borderlands you know that it's I
have you know there's no limit to the
weekend sort of embody and throw pie ads
and learn from so okay like I'm really
interested with the branding
going on cuz a sailor it looked like a
76 I also think that they're over over
in the Northeast because the cobblestone
huh are they in the Northeast cuz the
cobblestones I
say okay I'll see they're actually
closer to Alexandria than you then
you're thinking okay they're not closer
to Boston
okay okay I'll take that so I like that
given that they're close to Alexandria I
think you can't expect to see other
characters that you might know from a
comic where the show cool
possibly popping up here it's austerity
awesome so weird what's the control like
or not even control but I guess the
input from Robert Kirkman these days I
feel like in the beginning it seemed
like you guys were right there all the
time and I feel like now he's very much
like you know what you're doing
he I mean he is and we every one at Sky
than to not just Robert but Shawn maca
what's the whole team down there it's
it's a delicate balance because we've
kind of we're going down our own kind of
kind of channel here in a story that's
also tailored and there are characters
alive or dead in sort of your own Canon
that might be alive or dead and other
people's playthroughs yeah and we kind
of got to be very careful sort of where
we're cutting here so they they're just
they there we love working with them I'd
say for the third season because we're
budding so closely up against where the
comics are now it's presented that an
opportunity work of those guys even more
okay whereas for the first season Robert
and the team and skyvan there were
already so many issues with almost
hundred she's in when we started with
our own story back to the outbreak but
now that we're sort of right where the
comics are and where the story is it
does require a closer collaboration you
know there's that there residing that's
good I'm fun for you fun for everybody
I'm trying my hardest not to spoil
things I know it's tough for you how do
you guys look at the Walking Dead game
the same way Robert looks at the comic
where Robert always says it's a zombie
movie that doesn't end it's gonna go go
go go for you guys if you look at it
season by season and just like do we
want to do another one or do you have
season seven playing I think as long as
the fans keep playing them and keep
enjoying them we're gonna try and keep
making up so yeah we're not saying that
this at the end we're not here
an ounce like the next ten seasons but
you know this is this is this is this is
really at the heart of what we've been
doing for the last four or five years
we'd love to keep going let's get
through this third season first now
whenever we get to sit down and talk
about telltale my favorite question
always asks is how big are you guys now
oops
still not that big in comparison to some
of our Giants for everybody right now
you know I think when I started I was
around a hundred person there and now
somewhere between 350 and 400 now wow
it's a small city but you know we've you
know we've expanded everything still
sort of is done in our office in San
Rafael and we're in County not far from
you guys yet all this series all the
games that we're doing all the writers
and designers and developers were all
really on site we're all family
it's don't feel small do you think the
fact that you guys are a small family is
that the reason you've been duped by the
voice actor click I always talk about
you bringing my boy Baker in for one
game and suddenly it's Lauren Abbott's
Willingham's for a now Kat one Detroit
Batman yeah I actually have you to blame
for that I did this I think that you did
I think if you recall with VGA is 2014
was my birthday yeah you showed up with
Troy Baker I did you did and I was there
Kevin is there Pierre was there we got
the talking him I think that's actually
how we got in it's your fault do I was
do I believe a person a to get a ton
yeah I think so I'm not a lawyer or an
accountant but I will fight for you I
will fight for you thank you
you know grades the boys back to sue
yeah not a good one though I'm sure they
get him hired for any job gonna talk
with you I'll just do the talk show
yeah what what is your career Lego
character yeah I'm Aldrich Killian
Aldrich Killian yeah the bad guy from
Iron Man 3 he's Superboy Superboy and DC
Universe Online now are you in any way
going to interact with the Lego sloth
from the Goonies I know I don't think so
oh yeah well heck you want waiting yeah
you had to freak that when you saw that
right I lost my mind
yes was just talking to the guy from
Warner right over there I can't wait to
see it yeah your biggest duty fan I know
thank you you went up to what with a 13
anniversary what was it 30 day
anniversary was last year we are we did
a whole Minecraft series that was really
for the spirit of The Goonies yes
friends going on adventures
didn't you tell me yeah you like use the
Minecraft you used as a way to meet all
the people you wanted to for the goodies
we've got Corey Feldman horse thief
limping Shana hassle now Paul Rubens
isn't it
he wasn't in the game but I was like
Paul Rose was to the goodies like a
telltale like even though we're swear it
seems like we're were worlders I don't
know 350 sounds big but we we kind of
want different genres of stories out
there like so dramatic some you know
zombie apocalypse or tough you know
crime thriller Batman action
cheering and you know family
entertainment like minecraft it's like
it's kind of like a channel or like a TV
networks or this stuff for everyone
do not have to play every telltale game
so that's what I'll call it oh let's
have a goal I never listen all over a
failure this thing's over they're not
listening right now I think I think I'm
getting called by PlayStation right now
oh gotta go see Sid Schumer at the
PlayStation Blog fine okay oh yeah I
thought you really can see him on all
right before you go yeah with this guy
oh my god should never take my face I
help Safran giving you give me what am I
so what am I going for the show you turn
around show to people for Batman
congratulations Batman it's okay he's
quite awesome keep up the good work
Batman's off this number right episode 1
good look for premiere to tomorrow in
August
all right great it's gonna be open get
ready for Batman Gary for Walking Dead
get ready for more cons in here on
gamespot calm and of course kind of
funny calm when we come back or wherever
you go next or however the internet
works just subscribe to all the channels
I'm saying thanks